[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today Autumn is
in Denver hi Autumn welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey Dave and John how are you doing
today better than we deserve what's up
my husband and I
have trouble we've been together for
and we'd love to stay married but we
feel like we've tried everything when it
comes to managing our finances and we
just can't seem to agree the last step
that we have not tried is divorcing our
finances so I'm calling to ask if we
should divorce our finances
uh
what would that get you
well let me give you a little bit more
background
and had equal amounts of student loan
debt so we both had about 20 000 each so
we decided the easiest thing to do would
be combine our finances We Were Young we
didn't have any assets so it just made
sense
so however we both come from very
different financial backgrounds and I
tend to be on the offense and he tends
to be on the defense and we both feel
like we're pulling each other and
dragging each other Along on a path
financially that we don't want to be on
he was pretty steeped in fire the
financial Independence retire early
movement and would prefer to spend less
and retire very early uh he's 39 and 36
first perspective uh he'd like to be
retired tomorrow if he could and I
prefer slower burn I'd rather make smart
decisions on investments and work harder
and earn more to achieve our goals and
Lead maybe a more comfortable lifestyle
so if he retired today what we do with
the rest of his life
all the things that he enjoys he'd
probably still make money but that's
always the question he's built a life he
doesn't enjoy
not necessarily he just doesn't like to
work
so let me just cut to it this ends in
Ash Autumn because y'all aren't dealing
with the core issue
the core issue is you're trying to live
two independent lives next to each other
in the same bed
and until you decide on we want our life
to look like this and we're going to
reverse engineer it starting today to
build it together
you're going to be like Jim Halpert and
Michael Scott you're going to be
co-managers of this thing and then
eventually it falls completely apart
well we've made it work for the 15 years
and I had a 1994 F-150 that I duct taped
and glued together and made work for a
lot longer than it should have
healthy way to divorce our finances and
stay married and I'm going to tell you
the further along you go
trying to pretend that what John's
saying is when you agree on your
spending
and saving goals you've agreed on your
life and your life and your values
and you're not in agreement on those
things you don't have a husband then you
have a roommate
he actually come up with a yearly budget
an annual budget we do a piano if you
want to do it go do it when you called
and asked us we're not talking about
budgets we're talking about
your budget reflects unified values and
you don't have that
you have two independent people trying
to live independent lives and call it
something that it's not
okay
finances and say it was a busting you
know because oh Lord Jesus they can
knock your lights out you called me and
asked me they can say everything that
they want great great
what I'm telling you is this isn't about
money
hear me say that it's not about your
money it's not about your finances one
of the key things we learned in studying
10 000 millionaires was none of them
said I drugged my spouse into this
Kicking and Screaming almost all of them
said I had a unified plan with my spouse
that caused us to be able to achieve
these goals you are dreaming this is not
going to happen it's bad relationally
it's bad mathematically it's bad
financially you're wrong don't do it
this is the Ramsey Show